my name is Jake Donnell I work at
Twitter and I want to talk to you today
about leverage versus autonomy and a
large software system I I woke up with
another night and had some trouble
getting back to sleep so I edited my
slide so I'm interested to find out
what's in my slides this morning let's
see okay so let me start out by sort of
talking about the domain that I'm
talking about how many people here raise
your hand if you work for a big company
however you define that okay good
so maybe you'll understand some of these
problems I work at Twitter it's a big
company we have hundreds of people
collectively building the Twitter
software system and I want to talk about
this question how do you make good use
of these hundreds of people building a
large system so let's try to refine the
question a little bit what does it mean
to make good use of software engineers
one thing that might mean is that you
should your features faster it might
mean that you keep your cost down or it
might just mean that you're keeping
people happy I want to sort of
synthesize those and say that we want to
avoid wasting people's time because
we're going to help them ship faster
keep our costs down and also keep them
happy ok and how do we make good use of
people and we have a bunch of leverage
that we could we could move here we have
development processes training culture
things like that but I want to focus on
the software architecture that's that's
the question I'm interested in so here's
a here's a more refined wait as the
question how do you organize a large
software system so hundreds of engineers
working on it can avoid wasting their
time and I just want to give you a
caveat and these are my observations
about how things have gone on Twitter I
don't necessarily know what's going to
work in your environment but I hope it
gives you a useful way to think about
this problem ok so I want to start with
this idea from this sort of classic
management book by Andy Grove who was
CEO of Intel for a long time this is a
pretty good book but there's this one
part of it that really resonates for me
which is this idea of
how do you organize a big a big company
into teams you can have this you can
have a functional team which is a team
that's sort of focused on a specific
function maybe sales or recruiting or
managing your office or something like
that and that team benefits from
economies of scale and sort of from
specialization so it's doing one thing
it knows how to the team knows how to do
it well and there's a lot of leverage
for people outside the team if they want
some some recruiting done or some
marketing done they go to this team and
they don't have to put in a lot of
effort they get a lot of a lot of output
from that that efficient team on the
flip side a functional team has to deal
with a lot of different customers and
sort of juggle resources between the
customers a mission oriented team on the
other hand is sort of focused on a
particular product or business mission
and to end and performs a range of
functions they may you know start up
looks a lot like this obviously you do
all kinds of things in a start up but
you don't benefit from economies of
scale so much because your attention to
split all over the place
you don't benefit a lot from
specialization of your expertise but a
mission oriented team can work faster
because it doesn't need to wait on other
teams or compete with other teams for
resources and any growth put says that
you know speed is the only advantage of
a mission or hits a team but it's a
really big advantage and so
organizations tend to be hybrid in some
way that they have parts of them that
are functionally oriented in parts that
are mission oriented okay here's another
idea that I'm sure you come across
Conway's law which I've sort of put in
its trivial form here software tends to
look like the organization that builds
it kind of like pet owners tend to look
like their pets something like that and
this is sort of like it's funny because
it's true thing it's like software tends
to look like the organization to build
it because the builds is because people
have a hard time you know agreeing and
they all want to sort of do things there
in a way and so you end up with software
that reflects the the political rips in
an organization something like that
Conway was trying to say something a
little a little bit more refined
basically that the structure of the
design tends to follow the
organizational structure because of
communication because when you decide to
build a big system the first thing you
need to do is sort of split it up into
parts so that you can work on them in
parallel and that tends to fix the
structure of everything you do so you
you divide in two parts you define
interfaces you know we do this in
software all the time and that has a
huge impact on how the software ends of
being organized another way to put this
sometimes called Copeland's law is sort
of the negative of this which is that if
your software doesn't match your
organizational structure you have a lot
of problems you have a lot of split
responsibilities it can be difficult to
to operate your systems like this and
I'll give some examples of that coming
up this happens very often at least at
Twitter it's much easier to change the
org chart than it is to change the
software architecture and so you know
pieces of software mega move move it
around the organization but and so then
the match is not always perfect and then
there are aspects of software that are
really cross-cutting and so it's really
hard to sort of centralize them in a
single team ok so I want to sort of
synthesize these two ideas and basically
take any groves idea and apply it to
architecture so that if our systems are
centralized we get more leverage right
we can get more done with less effort if
our systems are decentralized we have a
lot more autonomy we can do it every we
don't have to wait on other people in
the organization or other systems in the
organization if you if your leverage is
poor you end up reinventing a lot of
wheels you waste time that way if you
don't have good autonomy you waste a lot
of time waiting on other teams and
dealing with over complicated software
I'll I'll give some examples of that
coming up ok
oh and I wanted to say a little bit
about the sort of global effects of this
trade-off between autonomy and leverage
so you can think of this as like a per
team choice like you work on a team at a
big company and you have a choice
whether to use something some piece of
infrastructure that the company provides
or to build your own you're anything but
the aggregate of all these team choices
has sort of global effects so let's see
I need to make my slide bigger I can't
see what I'm talking about
ok so there's some cost to having a lots
and lots of autonomy it can be really
hard to make global improvements across
the system if everyone has their own
little little world it can be difficult
to make other kinds of cross-cutting
changes like a feature change that
touches many systems there's a problem
of uncontrolled system complexity
because things are not very consistent
so different parts of your organization
may use different tools different
platforms whatever and that just creates
a lot of non-essential complexity on the
other hand there are some costs of
leverage and centralization as well you
have single points of failure and maybe
some monoculture risk so if everyone is
using the same platforms there may be a
security bugs that affect everyone at
the same time or something like that you
end up with arcane knowledge so they're
these centralized systems have sort of
gatekeepers or
Priya sooner than well but other people
outside don't really understand how
things work and have to rely on the
people who run those centralized systems
and then there's another there can be
another form of uncontrolled system
complexity which is poor modularity
so in some of these systems if
everyone's playing in the same code base
there's not good boundaries between
different parts of the system ok
so next I want to talk through a few
examples of how this sort of trade off
has played out played out at Twitter and
after that I'm going to tell you about a
new system that we've been working on at
Twitter that tries to slice this a
different way but let me start with
these examples oh sorry I think I missed
I missed a point there which so we have
this trade off but they're very often
sweet spots in the trade off where you
get a lot of leverage but you don't lose
a lot of autonomy so I want to start
with some examples of these sweet spots
okay so I started a Twitter in about
2010 where we had a big Ruby application
and we had a bunch of data center
machines and had to are people hearing
the feedback okay good
in our data centers we had to sort of
manually allocate systems to machines so
we we basically had a bunch of rack
machines and to get your service running
you needed to talk to the ops team get
machines allocated you get a list of
host names you had to set up while your
deploy scripts things like that
he was so there were two problems there
was the ops team was sort of the choke
point and there was a lot of ad-hoc
everyone had their own deploy processes
their own scripts and there was a lot of
duplicated to work because everyone had
to sort of bring machines up for their
service move forward to today almost
everything at Twitter is scheduled
through a cloud scheduler we have this
system called Aurora missus and it's
it's much much better so there's a huge
increase in leverage much less repeated
work it's much easier to get and change
your capacity the deploy process is
really regular there's sort of
infrastructure for that built into
Aurora so every service has its own
config file but that's sort of the
extent of the variation so this is sort
of a sweet spot you know because we're
leveraging economies of scale and
specialized expertise and we didn't
really have any important loss of a ton
it's true that people can't go yeah you
can still log into these machines but
you don't have quite the freedom you did
when you you owned a single data center
machine but it's not an important loss
of autonomy there isn't really anything
you want to do at least that we're doing
the benefits from that one thing to
notice about this is most customers want
kind of the same thing they just want a
place to run some run some code the
interface to this capability is
relatively simple so we have this
configuration that I was talking about
for defining a process running in Aurora
and most of the things running at
Twitter are on the JVM so that's kind of
the interface to the computer capability
it's pretty straightforward and another
another point here is that we did some
global system improvement from everyone
using the same system which is that the
team that runs it can continue to do
upgrades sorry we get much better
utilization out of the system so there's
kind of these these aggregate benefits
from everyone doing things the same way
there also
also are some downsides it can be
difficult to debug sort of platform
level issues if you have a performance
issue or especially a networking issue
you pretty much need to engage the team
that runs this and get their help on it
that can be hard to do autonomously and
very rarely we have bugs in the
centralized platform that bring down
large parts of Twitter that's sort of an
unavoidable risk of centralization but
it doesn't happen too often okay so I
want to talk about another sweet spot
let's see so again a long time ago at
Twitter we used the sort of raw Apache
thrift clients and servers for building
services and then worked fine they spoke
thrift but they lacked a lot of
important features for running a big
system they didn't have any notion of
service discovery you had to sort of
give them static host lists they didn't
have very good load balancing support it
really didn't have any failure detection
statistics tracing all these things were
missing they had poor async support as
well and we've since moved pretty much
everything at Twitter
uses this library called finagle which
embodies a lot of these features under
the hood so it has service discovery
integrated with Aurora has very
sophisticated load balancing and failure
detection it's got a multiplex transport
underneath I'm not sure if Apache thrift
has this these days but that's something
that we added it has good support for
stats and tracing that integrate into
other parts of our system and everything
is done all of our ascent calls are done
with features and that's pretty nice
so why is this a sweet spot so again
teams that use this get a ton of
leverage there's sort of continuous
improvement under the hood so the team
that earns finagle is constantly adding
improvements to how the balancing is
done - failure detection all these
things and again there's no really
important loss of autonomy the interface
to this is not very different from the
interface to the raw apache library and
again most customers want roughly the
same thing they just want to make some
RPC calls that's kind of true across the
system and we have some similar somewhat
similar downsides that it can be
difficult to debug issues in the
framework again you sort of need to
engage the finagle team of for many
performance issues things like that and
every once in a while if an ego bug will
take down a big part of Twitter but on
the whole it's it's a it's a huge
improvement ok so now I want to talk
about some sour patches the the opposite
of sweet spots and I want to start with
talking about the original Twitter
monolithic service after adding some
water okay so I'm sure probably heard
about this before but Twitter eight
years ago had a big Ruby app everyone
wrote code in the same system and this
had a lot of autonomy problems so it was
sort of a development and deployed check
point or a check point there was a
single deploy queue that everyone had to
get their branches into which broke all
the time it could sometimes take take
your days to get things through this
queue the code base was really
complicated and not very well organized
there wasn't
good sense of ownership it was all just
sort of one big bag of code and it was
quite easy to cause cross-cutting bugs
in the system on the other hand there
were some good things about it so there
were some things that were centralized
there was one code base there was one
git repo even though this deploy
pipeline could be frustrating there was
a team that ran the deploy pipeline
there was a CIS system that another team
ran there was observability built into
this and it was pretty easy to make
cross-cutting changes if you needed to
sort of the flipside of cross-cutting
bugs and there was good knowledge
specialization so application developers
could work in this Ruby code base and
there were other other teams that worked
on the Ruby VM for instance the deploy
as I was saying so people actually got
good leverage out of the system even
though it had a lot of problems so what
happened next well Twitter went really
big on micro services and I think the
main reason that we did this was because
of these autonomy problems the
perception was that if we were going to
keep scaling up the number of engineers
we couldn't have them all working on the
same code base that just wasn't that
wasn't going to fly so we we move to the
service-oriented architecture Oh hmm and
if you can see the colors on this maybe
not what I was trying to get across here
is that in this in this picture there
are some pieces of leverage you get from
working in this sort of container you
get you know CIO deploys I'll call
someone handle for you stats logging in
tracing and the the framework of
actually running the service when you
move to micro services every service has
to have all that stuff so the autonomy
is really good engineer's waste a lot
less time coordinating with one another
but there are these let's see yeah so
development of deployments are really
decentralized every team can deploy its
own code it's relatively hard to cause
cross-cutting bugs although it does
happen the code base is pretty well
modularized and there's good ownership
of different parts of the code
so those are good things for autonomy on
the other hand the leverage is not as
good so there are these pretty high per
service costs so setting up setting up
the framework again continuous
integration observability deployments
it's hard to make cross-cutting changes
in the system and those bytes that's
quite often and I kind of a related
thing is that there are a few choke
points for cross-cutting concerns so
there are certain things that you might
want to apply to the entire system like
maybe access control or something like
that and it's hard to find a place to
put that because the services all are
dealing with there and demands the
knowledge specialization is not very
good in this setup because to run one of
these services you have to know a ton of
things you have to know about your
application code you have to know about
all these different layers the
frameworks that they're using and you
kind of have to put all these pieces
together and just to be clear Twitter
has tons of support for this there are
lots of libraries and auxilary systems
that deal with all these things but you
still have to put all these pieces
together to to run a new service and
another problem here is that there's a
lot of really gratuitous variations so
there's a lot of very similar systems
that are just different for no good
reason because they're run by different
teams okay I want to talk in about
another or a few more cyber patches
there
one issue that's come up for us is that
we have so we split everything into
services largely on sort of application
nouns so there's a user service and
tweet service relationship services but
there's logic which is sort of
cross-cutting across these things and
there isn't really good place to put it
it doesn't really fit into any of the
services so we have this library for
dealing with cross-cutting logic and
it's it's kind of a problems how you get
a certain amount of leverage sorry I
should say this library is embedded in a
bunch of other services so maybe you can
see there begins to be a problem that
I'm with with autonomy which is that if
you want to make a change to this you
have to get a whole bunch of things to
deploy so it's not just that you're
stuck in one deploy queue you actually
have to run down
dozens of other teams to deploy this
library so that's pretty bad there's
also kind of a bad ownership problem
here which is that this library is not
you know we tried to split both the
services and the teams by these nouns
but for these cross-cutting things
there's not really a team that owns this
stuff and it's a little bit of a grab
bag of different feature logic and it's
it's hard to understand like who should
even earn it like it just doesn't
doesn't naturally break down into good
team ownership so it tends to be a bit
of a dumping ground for people's changes
they make feature changes and drop them
to this codebase and go away and no one
is really responsible for the long term
ownership so that's that's a difficulty
okay just a couple more this is maybe a
little bit surprising but there are lots
and lots of services at Twitter and not
all of them actually have owners so what
I tried to drive here was sort of
ownership boundaries of different teams
and there's a few that just kind of get
lost and and they keep running they may
even be really important but
surprisingly easy for things to get lost
or transferred to some team that doesn't
really own it or doesn't really
understand it or something like that so
this is sort of the consequence of
autonomy like if you you're not building
into a centralized system but you want
to build a feature so you bring up a
service for it and then you move to
another team or whatever it takes some
work to sustain these different services
ok one more so I think is a response to
the problems that I've been talking
about there's a strong pull to build
into existing services so it's it's a
lot of work to bring up a new one and so
people often just build into one that's
handy so that might be something that's
somewhat related to to the application
area that they're working in so a
pattern that often arises is the sort of
ad-hoc platform and what I'm what I mean
by that is that there's some service
which sort of grows to become a
container for multiple application areas
and the people who earn these so so one
model here is that there's the team that
ends the container and then other teams
that sort of contribute code into it for
different purposes
for those there's different purposes the
owners of those those bits of code get a
lot of leverage out of it because
they're relying on this other team to
maintain the container but they lose a
lot of autonomy just as with a monolith
they have to rely on the centralized
team for deploys it's easy to cause
cross-cutting bugs a big problem with
this is that these things tend to be
grown organically they're just sort of
driven by the pressures of you know
what's the fastest way that I can get
this piece of work done
well maybe building into an existing
system is easiest so they tend to be
pretty ad-hoc there are PC interfaces
are not always a good match for
everything that runs inside them or they
the RPC interfaces get really hairy
because they're trying to accommodate a
bunch of different things and the shared
components within that service also tend
to be kind of ad-hoc this hasn't really
been thought through from the beginning
so it's not well modularized okay so let
me tell you about this new system that
we've been working on
it's called Strato and it's sort of a
platform for micro services so what do I
mean by that we're trying to give
engineers more leverage without taking
too much of their autonomy so we have a
monolithic service that hosts lots of
micro services inside it the service is
developed and operated by a centralized
team users develop and deploy their
micro services configuration and we
provide some configurable pre-built
components that are sort of capture
common patterns at Twitter so a typical
pattern is you know I did a store with
the cash on top of it following some
schema that's easy to configure in a few
lines of of code all the micro services
running in strata form a catalog with a
common API that we can use in lots of
different ways and when you want to
write application logic in the system
you do it in a domain-specific language
called strata qaul which I want to talk
about a little bit so you might be
wondering this picture looks a lot like
the monolith picture except the
triangles or green instead of red so how
is this different from a monolith well
it is different so one thing we're
trying to do here is split the sort of
system's concerns from the application
concerns as much as possible so it
typical service of twitter mixes a lot
of concerns about our pcs and timeouts
and retries and things like that with
application code and we're trying to
split that out as much as possible let's
you write your application code in a
pretty stripped-down way and put the
system concerns in the platform as much
as possible another difference is that
these different micro services running
on this thing are pretty isolated so
they each have an interface just like a
throw service does typed interface and
it's not just a big bag of code where
everyone's calling everyone you actually
have some modularity so that's useful
we've split the deploys into a code
deploy for the platform and a config
deploy for the config and config to play
as much lighter weight than code deploy
we can do it much more frequently so
that means that different teams writing
micro services in strata can iterate a
lot a lot more quickly and a final point
is that because these micro services are
really small they don't they don't
involve a lot they don't have this whole
systems platform under them or sorry
they don't embody a whole system's
platform they can rely on the shared one
it's a lot easier for the org structure
to match the software architecture so if
the org gets moved around it's a lot
easier to move these little services
around than the big ones ok so let me
tell you a little more about that so you
might wonder why why do we need a new
language implementation for this why not
I don't know use Scala or something
that's what everything else is written
and almost everything else at Twitter so
one big issue here is that because we're
trying to run a shared platform we're
really concerned about control and
operability of the platform so we don't
really want a completely unbounded
language right we get a lot of advantage
from having a small and lightweight
implementation so we don't we're not
necessarily relying on the Scala
compiler in our service I think that
might be difficult we want to be able to
limit the supported language features so
we don't want people to be able to I
don't know right very heavy computations
or infinite loops in our system and
bring down the whole platform so we were
restrict the language in order to do
that we get a lot better control over
code loading you know may be weak
you can imagine doing something like
compiling out bytecode and loading byte
code into the system but that doesn't
give us a ton of control over exactly
how it happens and a final reason is
that we want to use types as
runtime objects quite a bit in this
system so from these configurations that
describe a micro service we have a type
describing the interface and we wanted
Jenner excuse me so we'd like to
generate serialization JSON interfaces
later I'll tell you about a graphical
interface that we have on top of this
and having those types as sort of
first-class runtime objects is really
useful if we were just working with JVM
bytecode maybe we could use the
reflection API or something like that
but it wouldn't be as easy and another
reason which I'll tell you a little bit
more about is that we'd like to have
some domain-specific features and it can
saw our domain of micro services what is
that demand it might may not seem like a
domain-specific idea at all but
something that happens very frequently
at Twitter is that a service will call a
whole bunch of other services and
combine the results in some way so there
are two things that we'd really like to
be easy in this system Twitter uses
thrift for all of its are pcs so we'd
like to make consuming thrift really
easy and because we're calling you know
dozens of services we'd like to make
concurrency really easy and these are
going to be two features that we provide
in this language can I get a show of
hands are people familiar with thrift
for the most part okay excuse me I'll
say a couple of things quickly about
thrift as they're relevant to this
language
okay so thrift RPC in three of Darby see
like many RPC systems you have an
interface definition language for
defining the interface between the
client and server you have a bunch of
types to describe this interface
primitives a few collection types
structs unions and enums you might call
those records and variants in another
language and one thing to notice about
this is the communication between
services is
effectively like structurally types so
you don't really care very much about
what the types are named it really just
matters what those shape is and thrift
extends this a little bit to this idea
of a compatibility relationship so you
may have two types that are not exactly
the same structurally but you can kind
of figure out how to get from one to
another in serialization so this turns
out to be really useful of course
because you may want to upgrade
different communicating services
independently and the way you go about
this is with optional and default valued
fields so if one side is expecting a
field sorry you add an optional field
now either side can expect it or not
expect it and you don't have a problem
with compatibility okay so let me go
back to telling you about static you
know this domain-specific language for
writing micro sources so it looks a lot
like scala really stripped down so it
has sort of the core of scala data
objects like tuples records variants
it has pattern matching functions the
usual stuff but it doesn't have a lot of
the fancier parts of Scala it's not
object oriented really at all it's kind
of focused on data structures and thrift
so not we don't care so much about
objects it doesn't have any of scholars
really fancy types if you if you do
scala you know that the type system is
quite complicated
one thing in particular we don't care
about is Java interoperability word
that's something that was a goal of
Scala's that we don't share that makes
the tip system much simpler in contrast
to Scala static us structurally types so
again I was saying that you know thrift
is sort of inherently structurally typed
because we're talking about a bunch of
communicating RPC services we we
followed that same thing that turns out
to be a good way to go about it and then
we have this sort of native support for
thrift data and I'll give you an example
of that but basically we don't want to
generate sort of stubs which may not
match our thrift domain very well we
just want to embed the thrift domain
directly into our language so every
thrift type is directly a type in our
language and that turns out to be really
convenient and anyone see the talk last
year
strangely about hexyl the big hammer for
concurrency one or two okay cool talk
you should go look it up if you haven't
seen it but strategy oh is influenced a
lot by hex Allah and we have this sort
of notion of transparent concurrency
built into the language and I'll show
you how that works okay so let me give
you an example of some strategy I'll
code so what we're gonna do in this code
is fetch some tweets and a user's
timeline from a few different micro
services that embody different data
stores and so we're gonna get a timeline
for Kim Kierkegaard - Ian if you don't
follow Kim you should check it out
so the first thing we're gonna do here
is look up a user object by by the
twitter name so that's this user by name
and fetch call here and we're going to
get back a thrift object representing
the user which has a bunch of fields
we're gonna pattern match on that to
extract the user ID field that's what
this this case user ID line is about and
then we're going to we're gonna call a
micro service that returns time lines
for a particular user ID so the home
time line for a user and what this is
going to return is thrift objects that
have an entry for each each tweet in
this time line that has a tweet ID and
author ID maybe some other fields again
we're going to pattern match this out
and next we're going to look up the text
of the tweet using tweet by ID and the
username for this user ID using user by
ID so this is kind of a contrived
example but this is pretty similar to
stuff that happens on Twitter all the
time we we have data scattered across a
bunch of different services and we have
to accumulate it together to produce
some result so you may wonder where's
the asynchrony in this we're making a
bunch of RPC calls how do we wait for
them again this is all sort of under the
hood so we're gonna compile this
language into an asynchronous
computation and we basically don't need
to worry about it at this level another
thing you might notice here is that it
seems like we're making a call to the
tweet by ID service and the user by ID
service for each entry in this time line
and that might turn into a
of RPC calls if it's a long timeline but
this is another feature of the this
concurrency library also influenced by
axel is that we can batch these things
together when we know we're sending
requests to the same service so we're
going to take this computation and try
to find all the things that are going in
the same place and put them into a
single batch so this is what executing
this competition it looks like okay so
we're going to call the user by name
service with Kim Kierkegaard get back
this UID pass it to timelines by user ID
and then we're going to make two batch
calls and I've tried to draw these thick
errors to indicate that we're making
about calls kind of simultaneously to
these two other services and when those
have both returned then we can produce
the result okay so how's this all
working out pretty well we've got a lot
of usage of the system at Twitter over
200 micro services are running in it
there's a lot of traffic it started to
approach some of our other big
centralized services we have been
building a graph QL layer on top of this
for use in our mobile clients and a nice
thing about that sorry I'm going to talk
about the nice we're also building a
hosted event processing system so
they're kind of like Amazon lambda where
we can use this language to write event
processors so it's pretty well is this a
sweet spot
yes or no so there's obviously a large
gain in leverage for users over writing
their own micro services we capture a
lot of common infrastructure and
configuration and people don't have to
operate things themselves that's sort of
centralized application logic owners
have a lot of autonomy because their
micro services are separated you know
they earn their own piece of code it's
not just a big bag of code and they have
they're sort of freed of this central
deploy queue they can deploy
configurations very frequently compared
to some of the other sweet spots I've
mentioned many customers want roughly
the same thing but there's a really long
tail of people who want different
so that turns out to be a little bit of
a problem this is not as simple as
system as some of the other ones that I
mentioned so we have some downsides here
the interface to this capability is kind
of complicated making a new language has
a really high bar the language
implementation and documentation
libraries that the language supports IDs
support all these things and a
centralized team having to be
responsible for all this becomes another
kind of bottleneck for people who want
to use it and as with these other sweet
spots that I mentioned it can be
difficult to debug platform level issues
and of course it started I was down many
micro services are done I see that I'm
running out of time so I just want to
briefly note that there's some emergent
benefits of a centralized platform so
this graph QL front-end I mentioned it's
hard to imagine how that would work if
it needed to front all of the different
micro sources at Twitter but having a
catalogue of services with similar
interfaces in Strato makes it much more
straightforward we have all this all the
types in one place it's very easy to
generate a graph QL interface from that
and I'll skip over to the next part i'll
skippered okay i want to make a little
conjecture here I think programming
languages are a good tool for building
the kind of sweet spot that I'm talking
about and I want to leave you with a
quote from Ginni and I consent he gave a
cool talk about how to tell when you've
accidentally written a language and what
to do about it any program was
sufficiently complicated user input
contains a computer programming language
implementation which is likely to not be
very well thought out I think what we've
tried to do with charter at least is to
think it out a little bit and make this
work well okay thank you I don't have
time for questions but if you want to
come talk to me after please do and if
you'd like to know more about static ul
I'm giving another talk later today
about the language implementation at the
Scala workshop so that's in the Frisco
room which i think is across the atrium
and upstairs if you're interested thank
you very much
you